[Musique]
c'est les habitations oui il est hyper
fort en imitation et je vous avais reçu
dans une émission et vous nous avez
offert votre imitation du velociraptor
est-ce que vous pouvez nous la refaire
ici ou est ce que voulait qu'on la passe
comme tu veux ce que vous pouvez nous la
faire en direct
ok ils avaient très bien le velociraptor
la face aux bas ici aller là où il n'y a
pas cet espace si jamais tu voulais
c'est juste un petit interrupteur et tué
alors dans ce cas là tu fais juste après
moi non mais moi je sais pas du tout
permet justement si ce rôle allez-y
faites le au fait combien
c'est la seule limitation vous faites
non je peux faire les hippocampes
situent eux ou alors vous êtes à leur
attention est la première fois qu il le
fait qu'un c'est parti pour le
velociraptor
[Musique]
la fin
m
rien
bravo
[Applaudissements]
il faut quand tu fais quoi comme votre
animal l'hippocampe jeu l'époque on
parlait l'hippocampe tension dernier à
l'écurie la balle la balle à la baleine
la bad la baleine et après l'écureuil
s'est même temps la baleine mais il n'y
a pas de chez vous les bras il est bien
les curés oui le prophète après philippe
joffard michael jackson ah ouais
d'accord oui c'est vrai mais attention
chez vous vous nous rejoignez il va
faire les curistes ça sera là c'est
filmé la wii si je vous fais un petit
peu 2 mars un appareil photo cl très
bien le dindon mais en fait je la
célibataire longtemps
le dob le dindon pour moi c'est moi qui
vous le dis je vais rester célibataire
traîneau les gens adorent les femmes
adorent les échos
elle est le dindon ces mots nous
rejoignent et fellow d'art dont j'adore
[Applaudissements]
donc toi toi tu fais hyper bien rihanna
kamwa way of te plaît fais l'amour mais
il faut la mise et uv laquelle si diageo
n'a rien amené katia
très trop bien dans cette chanson comme
étant mais j'ai fait mystère comment tu
fais bien mais c'est ouf
mais c'est i'm serrières dacca bois et
le papier mais qui au passage fait j'ai
envie de te le demander tout le temps
des vidéos mais tu fekitoa kamel la
bagarre
[Musique]